all right free agency has been in since
the early 90s as well it's become
something that makes the nfl
a a 12 month per year obsession
and a huge deal in the month of march we
have our highest traffic totals
of the year during this week of free
agency as everyone is looking to see
how their team is going to get better
and there are always
shouts of optimism from the various fan
bases out there as they see these moves
and and i've noticed a trend toward
making free agency a lot like the first
night of the draft where there's never a
bad thing
said about any one of these moves so
free agent signings and i'm going to
broaden it i'm going to take the license
here to broaden any of the moves this
week
that will cause us to say yeah well
because
trust me there aren't a lot of free
agency signings i'm going to look at and
say they're going to make us say what so
we got to be creative
any moves this week that eventually will
make us say what were they thinking
and here's the trivia question to
determine whether or not miles gets the
first pick the browns
won 11 games this year the most since
1994.
in 1994 vinnie testaverde started 13
games for the browns
who started the other three games that
year
at quarterback winning two of them
oh no this is bad i wow boy i said you'd
know it
you did say i'd known during the break
yeah
i have no idea like brett ripping i
don't know that's not right i don't know
who
who brett ripping i have no idea
oh you were so close should we give him
that one it was mark rippon
it was mark rippon what yeah
it was mark griffin
wow that's really interesting that i was
that close huh
okay yeah you were just making sounds
that's the thing you were just making
sounds and you were close
i had no i had no confidence that's what
happens when i have no confidence i'm
just like
yeah no but you are for you are familiar
with
with uh mark rippon former super bowl
mvp in fact he was a super bowl mvp
for the season during or that capped the
year in which you were born
so i would think you would know who mark
griffin is yeah
now you know my football consciousness
sort of starts like
in the late 90s like especially in 1999
that's the first super bowl i remember
god that is so depressing
so depressing you also gotta you also
gotta think like
i didn't have a football team in my city
from 1996 to
1998 so that's probably part of it
but yeah the greatest show on turf
that's that's the one that's seared into
my memory is the first one that i i got
in there
all right i got the first pick then and
and this is difficult because
look this year there weren't as many
business free agency decisions as there
were football
free agency decisions none of these
ridiculous over-the-top contracts
where somebody just wants to sell
tickets like an albert haynesworth type
of a thing
teams had less cap space they had to be
more strategic and surgical
in who they uh they actually
went ahead and signed um so i you know
i'm gonna i'm gonna predict
that um we are going to say
in a few years that what were the
patriots thinking when they paid matthew
judon
i i think that that's the one that
stands out to me that's that feels like
the one
that just because the way that defense
works
they really never have one guy in the
front seven
that generates a ton of sacks and a ton
of stats it's gonna be hard for him to
earn
the money and and i i just have a
feeling i just have a feeling
that of all the guys signed this week
and maybe the patriots went for sheer
volume and they understand some of these
guys aren't going to work out i think
judon's the one
that the patriots signed in a few years
that we're going to say maybe they
shouldn't have done that
yeah i mean there are definitely going
to be some from the patriots just
by like you said sheer volume that we're
going to be like whoa i can't believe
that they actually signed that guy
when they then went on to win what 10 9
11 games that it's going to be because
that's just seems to be who the patriots
are
um but so i'm glad that you said that we
could expand this to any move that was
made because i was just going to do it
anyway because you have a tendency to
break the rules so i was just going to
do it
but von miller with the broncos i think
is going to be something that we're
going to look back on
even you know in the regular season this
year and be like wait a minute
why did the broncos decide to pay him 18
million
when this is the production that they're
getting out of him because look
we just don't know a how healthy von
miller is going to be
and b if he's going to be the guy that's
going to get to double digit sax again
if you look at what he did
in that last healthy year that he had in
2019 he only had eight sacks
and so is he going to be the von miller
that we knew
you know the von miller that was mvp of
super bowl 50
i just don't quite know and i don't know
how much that really makes them better
even though it's almost like you're
doing a back pay thing like
you made us so good von you're one of
the best players we've ever had
in franchise history yes we want to
reward you for that but
i think especially in a year with the
depressed cap you gotta pay guys for
what they're going to do not what
they've done
i i still hold out the possibility that
new gm george payton
has made a 7 million gamble that by
guaranteeing that portion of von
miller's salary of 18 million
they preserve the ability to trade von
miller i
i i think that that potentially is on
the radar screen because
since payton is new to the organization
he's got nothing invested emotionally in
von miller he can view him purely and
simply
as an asset like these teams view all
players but when you have no history
with a guy it's even easier that's
something to keep in mind next one for
me
i'll say shaquille griffin even though
it's only a three-year deal with seattle
seahawks
that one this guy isn't regarded as one
of the top
corners he was available and i think the
jaguars are just
spending because they can spending
because they want their
fans to buy season tickets this is all
new to urban meyer and i've heard
some criticisms from and and look it's a
competitive field and i don't like to
dabble in these
objective anonymous opinion not
objective but
subjective anonymous opinion slight
difference uh but but
one of the criticisms is what what do
they think and paying all that money to
shaquille griffin so
if it's good enough for people around
the league to think it's good enough for
me to think too
okay that's interesting i mean i think
that that's it's one of those things
where if you're trying to turn around a
one in 15 team you've got to overpay for
some people
even if you know you don't think that
they're all that great
so maybe it works out maybe it doesn't
but i think that that one could be one
where you're like
scratching your head a little bit later
i have probably like
three raiders things that i could go to
their entire week has been very
confusing to me but i'm gonna go with
kenyon drake
because he's somebody who's good
he's fast you know he is somebody that
can make plays
but when you have somebody like a josh
jacobs who you want to be your every
down back you want to be your bell cow
you want to be the workhorse
and then also you you know get rid of a
lot of the offensive line and
some of those guys have still been there
um so it's not like they're integrating
completely new people
but you're also guaranteeing him a five
and a half million dollar roster bonus
this year what's what's that about i
i don't know about all that for a
running back like and then
i read that they want to have him in the
lynn bowden role which
you know does that mean that they're
going to trade him in august before he
ever plays a snap for the team
i don't know i guess if that's what they
want that's what they could do but that
one that one was a head scratcher for me
unless they plan on having kenyan drake
gain a hundred pounds and play right
guard
the move made no sense to me whatsoever
because you're right
josh jacobs is the guy who's the banger
for them he's the guy they built that
running game around
and i'm surprised drake wanted to go
there with an incentive-laden deal
uh unless unless the raiders
are still cooking up some sort of a
trade package for russell wilson that
will include josh jacobs
let's not rule that out completely derek
carr
josh jacobs jonathan abram three
first-round picks
can't rule anything out with john gruden
we've seen how unpredictable he can be
just this year don't don't rule that out
uh maybe that's the explanation for it
all right
um next one for me
hmm boy i'm i i i alway i don't want to
get 20 emails why do you hate the ram so
i'm gonna skip this one i'm gonna say
the decision of the bears to not rescind
the franchise tender
from alan robinson that's more of a
short term but also a long term what
were you thinking because
they visited with kenny gallaudet they
clearly were thinking
about dumping the the franchise tag for
robinson
17.9 million when we look back at the
cap
impact of this year how it's going to
affect teams in the future because it's
less money you can carry over to future
years some teams are going to have more
some will have less it's a lot of money
to invest in alan robinson in the
depressed market they'd have been better
off stripping that tender
and going out and finding other
receivers elsewhere as that market
softens and softens and softens i
i otherwise was going to say why did the
rams put a first round tender on darius
williams
uh because that that is a waste of a
million and a half dollars for a team
that desperately needs the money
i was just gonna say that because i like
that's something that i know you wrote
about because i read that
article from you mike so there we go i
read those texts too it's call back to
earlier in the show folks there
yes uh but i'm going to go with uh trey
hendrickson for
from the bengals um for my life here
because yeah
you think so i just think without cam
jordan on the other side of him
he's probably going to struggle and look
if cincinnati
is what cincinnati is we don't know if
they're going to be any good or not i
mean
i you know you want joe burrow to do
well especially after coming off the
knee injury
but i just i don't know i think that
that signing in particular when he
doesn't have somebody
opposite him that's really good that one
could go down was one of those where
you're really scratching your head
they let carl lawson walk for 15 million
a year and they pay trey hendrickson 15
million a year and the point i always
make in free agency
the fact that the guy is even available
that the team that had him for multiple
years didn't want to keep him
is a red flag in and of itself so we'll
see how these moves work out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports